die explosion am himmel war unnatürlich
hell und gibt astronomie teams weltweit
rätsel auf zwei teleskope des atlas
projekts auf hawaii hatten das
mysteriöse objekt entdeckt mittlerweile
wurde es von mindestens 24 teleskopen
genauer untersucht und die fachwelt ist
in aufregung denn so etwas habe man noch
nie im universum gesehen einen namen hat
das objekt allerdings schon wird alles
was er noch zu dem mysteriösen
phänomenen wissen müsst jetzt bei pixum
science fiction herzlich willkommen die
explosion am 17 juni 2018 war ein ganz
besonderes phänomen wie kate major eine
mitarbeiterin des atlas projekts
berichtet die explosion ist wirklich wie
aus dem nichts aufgetaucht
entdeckt wurde sie von zwei teleskope
auf hawaii schnell musste ein name her
und den bekam das objekt dann einfach
durch die zufällige zuweisung von
buchstaben 2010 cabrio oder abgekürzt
ebene kaum noch immer ist nicht klar
wobei sich bei der explosion gehandelt
hat fest steht das objekt zeigte sich
extrem hell etwa zehn bis 100 mal heller
als eine supernova wie wir sie kennen
deswegen gegen die forschungsteams auch
zuerst davon aus dass es aus unserer
galaxie stammt mittlerweile wurde diese
angabe korrigiert vermutlich stammt das
objekt aus einer galaxie die 200
millionen lichtjahre entfernt ist ihr
name
cg cg 100 service ethics and schon bald
richteten sich nicht nur zwei sondern
mindestens 24 teleskope weltweit auf das
phänomen am himmel mittlerweile weiß
waren das die explosion nicht nur
besonders hell sondern auch besonders
schnell war die energiereichen teilchen
schossen mit etwa 20.000 km pro sekunde
nach außen ihr oberflächentemperatur
schätzen forschungsteams auf bis zu 9000
grad celsius
und es geht weiter mit äußerst
ungewöhnlichen messwerten
denn die beobachtung zeigten dass die
explosion tatsächlich auf allen teilen
des elektromagnetischen spektrums
besonders selber von der
röntgenstrahlung angefangen bis zu den
radiowellen in nur wenigen tagen hatte
weg ihre stärkste helligkeit
erreicht ein großer unterschied zu den
supernovae wie wir sie kennen denn diese
brauchen dazu meist mehrere wochen eine
vermutung ist nun dass es eine supernova
gewesen sein könnte und zwar vom typ 1 c
das bedeutet dass in einem riesigen
stern der kern zusammengebrochen ist und
seine äußere hülle jung und wasserstoff
verloren hat doch wie kam es dazu
normalerweise ist der radioaktive
zerfall von nickel dafür verantwortlich
doch die beobachtete explosion war dafür
deutlich zu schnell und zu hell und viel
mehr details sie gibt es immer noch
nicht die explosion gibt weiter rätsel
auf zitat etwas vergleichbares habe ich
noch nie gesehen
es muss sich um ein sehr seltenes objekt
handeln das sagt beispielsweise der
irische astrophysiker stephen smart in
einem interview mit der washington post
das große rätselraten um vi cao derzeit
verdeutliche unser nicht wissen im
bereich der astronomie und physik
weitere messungen und analysen sind
jetzt aber in planung und werden uns
bald vielleicht mehr zu wirkt verraten
doch selbst die forschungsteams selbst
sehen das erst in einigen monaten wenn
ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollte dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die etwas
unkalkulierbare abo box hier auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video game awards
erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem
upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen
täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
und auf keinen fall die genau die glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken wird ein gamma
blitz die erde zerstören der hellste
blitz aller zeiten bis dann bleibt dran